This fresh, juicy, pulpy red ball is a part
of most of the delicacies that we relish
while eating.
But can you tell me whether a tomato is a
vegetable or a fruit?
Some say it is a fruit, while others say it
is a vegetable!
And which is the right
answer?
Let us find that out!
To know this, we must first know what exactly
a fruit is!
For a lay person, it is
simply a pulpy sweet edible part of a plant.
But a botanist will define it
precisely in a different way!
A fruit is defined as a seed bearing structure
which
is actually the ripened or mature ovary developed
post fertilisation.
So in a typical flower, after fertilisation,
the petals wear off, this part, that is
the ovary, develops into the pulpy fruit,
and these ovules into seeds.
So this is how a typical fruit appears to
us!
Right?
Yes!
This is how it looks when cut!
Now if we were to label this fruit, we would
basically divide it in two major parts.
This central region, as the seed, and the
surrounding pulpy region as the Pericarp.
The seed mainly has the embryo, which is located
here.
This is surrounded by
the nourishing tissue called endosperm.
And this complete unit is surrounded
by a tough covering called the seed coat meant
mostly for protection.
The pericarp on the other hand is the edible
part.
It consists of the outermost,
thin, epicarp or also called the exocarp.
The word originates from the Greek
words “epi” meaning above or upon and
“carp” meaning fruit.
So this is the
outermost layer present on the fruit.
Next is the middle layer called Mesocarp.
The term “meso” in Greek means “middle”
and “carp” as we know is “fruit”.
This is usually pulpy or juicy in most of
the fruits.
So it is mainly this part which
is consumed by animals when a fruit is eaten!
Lastly, we have the “endocarp”.
The term “Endo” means “within” or
“inside”.
So it is the last layer of the
Pericarp which surrounds the seed.
Depending upon the fruit, endocarps can
be either membranous or thick.
These were the parts of a typical fruit.
Now tell me, do all fruits have this kind
of structure only?
Do they all look similar?
No, right?
Fruits like pineapple,
berries, almonds, and melons….
All of these look completely different.
So don’t
these have the layers that we just discussed?
Of course they do!
Yet these
fruits are different from each other!
That means fruits come in various types!
So let us understand the various types of
fruits in detail.
Classification of fruits can be done in a
variety of ways.
We will have a look at
the two major ways of classifying fruits.
The first basis is on the parameter of
the morphology of the fruit.
And the second parameter would be the part
of
the plant from where the fruit develops.
Let us begin with each, one by one in the
next part!